des 14 femmes assassinées.
Le 6 décembre 1989, Marc Lé
a semé la terreur à la
Polytechnique. Il a abattu
Un attentat antiféministe
EDITH DUCHARME, récipiendair
bourse Ordre de la rose blanche
- De savoir que des femmes ont
parce qu'elles étaient
des femmes, c'est quelchchchose
qui vient me chercher
très personnellement.pour Éditht
récipiendaire de la boursede la,
une récompense remise
aux étudiantes en génie.
ces étudiantes qui n'ont pas pu
terminé leurs études, fait que
chaque année, je viens porter
des roses de nos souvenirs des
avec eux.
,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,
des gens se sont réunis au son
de la cérémonie, diffu
sur Internet.
- Le 6 décembre, c'est toujours
imprégné de tristesse.
- Une trispapapapartagée,
des fleurs comme témoins.
- À 17 h 10...
- Genevinononononononononononons
assasinées a résonné à Montréal.
Une roososososée pour chaque vie
perdue, une lumière
pour chacune.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
- Événement que l'on refait
à chaque année.
Pour penser à elle, penser aux
familles, mais également avoir
une réflexion en tant que
société sur ce q
fait pour empêcher la violence
faite aux femmes
féminicide.
prémier ministre du Québec
- On a vraiment un dev
de mémoire.
On a vu malheureusement encore
de la violence pour les femmes
- Ailleurs au
des universités, comme celle
de Moncton, ont souligné
la tragédiecocococococococococo,
les députés canadiens se sont
recueuilenenenenenence
en souvenir des victimes.
Des commémorations qui
se de e e e e e e e e e e e e e.
MÉLANIE EDERER, présidente de la
d d d d d des femmes du Quebec
- Au bout de 18 féminicides
cette année, on sent qu'il y a
s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s ss
d'action à la fois de rappelerme
cet attentat antifeministe
et à la fois agir pour les
- Des victimes qui pourraient
crouler sous les balles.certaint
- Après 32 ans, ce qui me
frappe, c'est vraimentcomme nous
familles continuent, doivent
continuer à se battre pour un
meilleur contrôle des armes
alors que la grande majorité du
que surtout pour les dernières
années on a élu un gouvernement
sur la bntntntntntntntntntntntns
armes.
laxiste, selon PolySeSouvient.
Le rachat des armes d'assault
interdites est volontaire
Les armes de poing toujours
légale, à moins d'une
L'attentat survenu le 6
décembre 198ntntntntntntntntntni
est toujours en force...et qui
trouve édidididididididias
sociaux
MÉLISSA BLAIS, professeure
de sociologie (UQO) et autrice
- Le web en fait c'est comme une
loupe.r r r r r r r r r r r r re
discours. Ça donne l'impression
de force et de grandeur.
- Pour que jamais plus ne
s'éteigne la lumière des y
des femmes parce qu'elles sont
- Nul besoin de s'identifier
comme féministe pour ê
cible. De répertorier et
d'alerter également quand ça se
produit parce que si on est visé
comme féministe, il se
que d'autres femmes soient